pardon pour cette interruption des
programmes mais un événement grave s'est
produit aujourd'hui à neuilly sur seine
[Musique]
un homme a reprise en otage les enfants
d'une classe maternelle
le preneur d'otages exige une somme de
100 millions de francs
l'homme revolver en main affirme avoir
une bombe
il a dit qu'il préférait mourir plutôt
que d'être pris vivant qu'il serait prêt
à se servir des enfants comme bouclier
pour protéger sa fuite
les enquêteurs pour la certitude d'être
devant un homme déterminé et qui a
préparé minutieusement son scénario et
qui ira jusqu'au bout qu'ils s'étaient
fixés
[Musique]
non aucune
au cabba a bien dormi
[Musique]
josiane
à des clones on se lave les mots fille
camille n'a accueilli césar on reprend
place on va pas faire de gymnastique
aujourd'hui c'est bientôt la fête des
mères on est un petit peu en retard
alors on va finir l'écologie comme à nac
puisque vous voulez vous n'avez rien à
faire ici sortais de ma classe les
enfants on n'avait que les activités
clés tels le coloriage la lecture et à
vélo rail au peter pan
[Musique]
tout à coup je vois l'institutrice de la
classe numéro 8 laurence dreyfuss arrivé
dans mon bureau un peu affolés en me
disant il y à une prise d'otages
quelqu'un est dans ma classe il veut que
vous veniez sûr vous allez mais qu'elle
peut quitter cette classe vous voyez
bien que ce sont des enfants
bon allez maintenant vous partez
monsieur une dernière fois je vous
demande de sortir vous n'avez rien à
faire dans cette école pour qu'ils
allaient sortir cette classe vous allez
faire ce que je vous demande au nez
cette feuille on est là sans la porte et
pêchu
[Musique]
ceci est une prise d'otages je porte
sûrement un sac bourré d'explosifs
capable de tout détruire autour de moi
et je suis déterminé à tout faire sauter
sans aucune pitié ni hésitation si je
suis menacé ou si un seul policiers
pénètrent dans la classe fait évacuer
l'école en commençant par les classes
voisine utiliser tout votre personnel
pour interdire l'accès de la place à
toute personne et aux policiers en
particulier fait prévenir au plus vite
et par an je m'occupais des enfants
[Musique]
on met tout ça on va prendre un petit
bouquin mais on va tous s'asseoir sur
les bancs avaient tous une petite chaise
pour s'asseoir
[Musique]
voyez faire attention
pas de quoi racheter du matériel cette
année c'est un guichet
pourquoi vous faites ça
[Musique]
l'attentât données signé hb il bombe a
explosé dans un parking
oui
j'ai la jeune chevrette des montagnes et
très intrigués par les deux petites
bosses point de thurac 1 to de jolis
korneuburg juliette ravine on dit pour
annoncer la nouvelle à son voisin
ça
[Musique]
moi aussi s'écrie le chamois et les
miennes seront bien plus hautes et bien
pur au cours des collections toujours
comme et la vidéo
[Musique]
les fenêtres du couloir
trop petit trouver une solution
vous n'êtes pas contents de la caisse à
vous même dépêchez vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est là le ramassent ensuite l'index la
casse est super je me présente je suis
aimé touitou je suis le directeur
départemental de la police
je suis parmi nous en prison
[Musique]
directeur départemental de la police
je vous montrer ma carte je suis pas à
emmener inquiétez pas
voilà je suis là pour vous aider
pourquoi est ce que vous retenez ces
enfants dites moi ce que vous voulez
santé
il s'agit de gosses qui s'entend quand
même susceptible d'être en danger
ce qui veut dire que le dispositif le
plus important et est enclenchée saisine
un criminel saisine du raid pour la
partie opérationnelle
je suis au stand de tir à versailles
là où on s'entraîne habituellement fin
d'exercice spécifique qui se trouve être
le double tap
du coup rapide l'un derrière l'autre on
alpha pages le rappel de bip
vulgairement sam a sonné et donc nous
demandent de revenir d'urgence au
service pour une bonne prise d'otages
[Musique]
il arrivait sur place et est assez
délicate parce que il n'y a pas
véritablement de périmètre de sécurité
qui a été établie on arrive là et qui
est responsable de quoi
les gens qui sont sur place disent leur
aide on est tranquille il ya que
maintenant mon engagement et nous on
arrive mais on n'a pas encore pris
toutes les clés en main premier élément
d'appréciation c'est le faire lui-même
d'une prise d'otage des enfants c'est
quand même pas banal c'est pas tous les
jours que ça arrive ya quand même une
charge émotionnelle symbolique très
forte mais le deuxième élément tangible
qu'on a c'est ça c'est clair
c'est bien écrit c'est ses propres
bateaux orthographe et ça semble très
très cohérent et très organisée là des
revendications écrites on sent que ça va
être quand même être sacrée épine à ça
fait problème quoi ici bon niveau rez
téléphone
[Musique]
mais que faire du zèle est ce que je
t'ai étaient vos revendications sont
précises et on a quand même besoin de
dialoguer je vais installer un téléphone
je me mets sur la chaise
comme ça vous pourrez nous appeler sorte
et ça y est c'est fini
les enfants regardez moi mes choix
[Musique]
si il est vrai qu'il a un système
d'explosifs et de mise à feu à double
effet un j'appuie ça explose mais je
relâche s'expose aussi le risque est
énorme et les capacités d'intervention
qui sont extrêmement limitées c'est
quelque chose qui correspond à une
grenade à ces mêmes principes que la
grenade
partant de là on se dit que là l'aspect
intervention pure est complètement à
mettre de côté et on doit privilégier au
maximum la négociation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je prends en chemise à col là une foule
incroyable accrochée aux grilles des
policiers partout une espèce de panique
générale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas qui m'adresser et je vois
une femme crs est justement le donne mon
nom de ma fille claire pagès et elle me
dit ah oui votre fille dans la classe du
preneur d'otage laurence et une prise
d'otages à neuilly diane fait partie des
otages
et là j'ai cru que tout s'arrêtait je me
suis complètement figé je crois que je
me souviens d'avoir hurler
c'est une note il ya des gens qui crient
qu'ils eurent et je rencontre quelqu'un
que je connais elle vient me voir et me
dit t'inquiète pas pour tous les enfants
j'étouffe j'ai récupéré tout le monde
c'est ta fille et vient avec moyennement
mène devant la devant des policiers qui
me demandent mon nom et là je suis
emporté par trois policiers
on essaye de fendre la foule mais c'est
vraiment difficile et je suis projeté
dans l'école et là il ya quelqu'un qui
vient boire et qui me dit voilà il ya
quelqu'un dans la place de votre fille
il peut pas elle peut pas sortir
maintenant et et voilà et c'est comme ça
que ça a commencé
qu'est ce que tu veux je voir la carte
d'identité de ministre de l'intérieur et
j'avais en main propre je vais sur qui
le courant de ce qui se passe je la lis
des parents qu'est ce que tu veux faire
de la liste des parents je voir les
parents après libérer des otages le
directeur de cabinet me dit monsieur le
ministre je vous parlais quelque chose
de grave lève et effectivement il me dit
à une prise d'otages ali g bas rhinois
qui est tellement conseiller à la
communication était avec moi on se
trouve que lui à une petite fille dans
une école maternelle à neuilly est ce
que c'est celle là est rapidement oui
c'est celle là
la diane qui était dans l'école qui est
qui en otage et il me dit mais je le
sais j'y vais j'y vais c'est hors de
question vous ne vous n'y allez pas
écoutez monsieur voyait un oui à la
police il ya les gens pour ça alors il
me dit je vais y aller j'ai des jeux
interdits vous m'avez rien à y faire
je dis rien et je fonce l'école charcot
à fond de train or j'arrive là-bas à
l'école de ma fille dans une cour où il
y avait effectivement les gens du raid
qui venait s'installer il continué en
voir à s'installer
je tombe sur bayon
écoutez aussi il faut mais changez vous
mais changer si vous avez une idée en
tout cas à les y tue le père d'un enfant
tu veux le voir
[Musique]
tu vois c'est le père d'une enfant tu
veut l'échanger
[Musique]
bon alors tu veut l'échanger tu veux
qu'il reste bon
[Musique]
acculé
m
100 ha
[Musique]
ce geste dans ma tête il m'a fallu à peu
près dix ans pour que pour qu'il s'en
aille
ce geste
[Musique]
mon mari s'avance vers moi accompagné
d'un homme du raid il est blanc et
livide
il veut me prendre dans ses bras c'est
vrai une réaction nous en mai tu as
diane il me dit non diane s'est avancé
vers moi je ne les ai pas prises à
partir de ce moment là je reste figé en
plein milieu de la cour et j'attends
d'ailleurs marc mercier est et moi je
suis resté comme ça pendant un moment et
tout à coup il ya eu un policier qui
s'éteint il m'a dit non
il vient de distribuer une lettre gym
fait lire la lettre
je ne vois qu'une seule phrase c'est une
phrase mais horrible épouvantable
il sera pratiquée sur plusieurs d'entre
eux y reçut plusieurs enfants une
opération de prélèvement sanguin avec un
débit variable pouvant conduire à des
séquelles importantes ou bien la mort
une fois passé leurs limites
les autres parents ce sont
dans le gymnase est pratiquement dès le
début mon rôle consiste à aller les voir
et je discute avec eux j'essaie de les
rassurer et je m'engage avec eux à les
tenir informer toutes les demi heures ou
toutes les heures de l'évolution de la
situation
on est calme on est tous dans la tente
mais dans une
dans l'esprit que ça va se terminer
c'était ce n'est ce n'est pas grave
enfin il faut il faut il faut se dit
c'est ça va c'est la sphère de quelques
de quelques minutes en fait je m'auto
protège je me dis il peut pas arriver
quelque chose à ma fille donc je je non
je joue
je quelque part j'ai conscience pas tout
de suite en fait quelque part j'ai
confiance mais très vite je dis non
patron du raid s'approche de moi et
m'explique la situation il me dit est ce
que vous êtes prêts à rentrer et j'ai
tout de suite répondu oui je peux
rentrer tu vois on fait des efforts il
ta porte de l'argent vingt mille francs
raphaël non non
à garder le contrôle de bon au sort
[Musique]
j'ai mon fils dans les bras tu qui
pleure non pas parce que il a vécu
quelque chose de grave à l'intérieur
mais ils pleurent parce qu'il voit des
gens masqués tout autour de lui les gens
du raid voyant ça on tousse tousse
tousse enlever leurs masques et tous ont
un sourire vis-à-vis de mon fils et et
vis-à-vis de moi
il peut pas se permettre de garder ne
serait ce que pour sa sécurité aussi
autant d'enfants dans cette casse avec
tous les explosifs et les enfants qui
bougeait autour des sujets explosifs etc
donc il faut qu'ils lui aussi il faut
petite île en hiver quelques-uns pour
pouvoir réussir bien son opération telle
qu'il assure être en jeu une radio une
radio à non d'accord on va loin viendra
plus tard d'accord il était libéré
depuis ce matin ans trois fois en ce
moment tout le titre du petit prétan
flatte le quartier bouclé la police et
les hommes du raid ont postés sur les
immeubles alentours et dans les
bâtiments de l'école
le service de déminage est également à
pied d'oeuvre les pompiers et les
ambulances des médecins stationnent dans
la cour bref tout est prêt et tout le
monde est à son poste paraît à la
moindre éventualité et j'apprends
l'instant que deux autres enfants
viennent d'être libérés ce qui porte à
onze le nombre d'enfants libérés en 4 x
donc par ce preneur d'otage une chose
très important paris pierre chany qu'est
la personnalité
de l'homme qui a pris en otage il a
demandé à parler à un émissaire de
l'intérieur c'est donc un homme
déterminé et lucide qui détient tous ses
petits enfants en otage jésus la
trouille de ma vie je pars comme une
voleuse je pars avec mon enfant
j'assimile ça comme je pense à une
victime d'attentats qui qui échappe à
une explosion de bombe
moi j'ai vu sur le coup je n'ai aucune
aucun état d'âme je ne pense pas aux
autres parents je ne pense qu'à sortir
de là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
formation c'est du raid sont sur place
les motivations du preneur d'otages
reste encore assez obscure il aurait
réclamé 100 millions de francs et il
demande à voir le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur charles pasqua des
concessions ne sont plus celles des
pères ils ont besoin de sortir tes
normal qu'ils soient dans cet état y
sont fermées depuis ce matin ont
polarisé les calmants
sur scène parce que nous revoyons
ensemble et tout derniers éléments
d'information une précision d'importance
au rang des très petits enfants alors
les amis je vous lis re max et les
maximonstres maintenant et par leurs
enfants et recule aussi en otage voilà
comment les choses peut pas tout à
l'heure le ministre du budget était
maire de neuilly-sur-seine nicolas
parfois qu'il est arrivée sur les lieux
les outils est tout prêt lorsque le chef
du réseau ibai on me sort de l'arrivée
de sarkozy
j'ai une réaction tout de suite très
très spontanée je lui ai dit on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge ministre sur
place pourquoi l'arrivée d'un ministre
pose problème c'est que lorsque un
ministre harry bhl il nous faut protéger
c'est quand même un membre du
gouvernement
deuxièmement en ayant tout de suite
ministre sous la main le preneur
d'otages peut avoir la volonté de
demander une personnalité ministériel
supérieur c'est pas nécessairement bon
d'avoir un personnage déjà aussi haut
placé dans une négociation parce que
après est ce qu'on peut faire après ce à
quoi donc c'est aussi un peu piégeant
donc le nomme à mesure du possible on
évite ce genre de intermédiaire en fin
d'instruction de négociateurs déjà
incertain si haut niveau
[Musique]
allauch toi aller
quelqu'un qui veut te parler tu vas voir
c'est quelqu'un de connu vous pouvez y
aller j'apporte la carte d'identité du
ministre de l'intérieur
en échange de la libération d'un enfant
[Musique]
oui ce sont ses papiers
je vous transmets qui à charles pasqua
le message que va vous remettre
l'institutrice et je le sens millions de
francs avant 16 heures
donnez moi le message madame donner le
message et moi je donne aux ministres
je reviens vous voir et je ramène
l'argent
il explique que il est quelqu'un qui a
pris un certain nombre de dispositions
réelles pour provoquer la mort des
otages
s'ils n'obtiennent pas satisfaction et
plus ils demandent de nantes 100
millions vous voulez dire 10 milliards
anciens oui mais 10 milliards anciens
c'est un camion entier il faut 48 heures
pour réunir cette somme là moi je ne
peux pas ne me demandez pas ce que je ne
peux pas vous donner si je pouvais je
vous en donnerai triple je suis
quelqu'un de sérieux
vous êtes quelqu'un de sérieux je peux
pas vous trouver 10 milliards comme ça
je peux pas vous les importez comme ça
avec une camionnette
quand vous allez faire pour les
transporter je vous en supplie
donnez-moi écosse pour prouver vous êtes
un brave homme à qui je peux parler
aller à la haye les deux donnez moi le
plus fatigué donnez moi le petit quai
devant la wii voilà ça prouve à vous
êtes quelqu'un de bien vous êtes
quelqu'un de bien parce que vous libérer
les enfants allaient maintenant qu'on me
donnait une petite fille donnez moi le
petit garçon et pourquoi pas la petite
fille se branche à blanchir son nom mais
c'est une petite kate a adopté regarder
aller même pas française qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait cette meule à la tombe de
fatigue il faut que je puisse terminer
avec moi longtemps que vous aurez un cos
personne fera quoi que ce soit contre
vous parce que je vous le dis la gauche
y tient comme si c'était rieurs l'heure
pas ma chérie donnez moi la petite je
veux sortir avec les deux j'en veux un
dans chaque bras et je reviens vous voir
ou alors donnez moi le petit noir à
aller donner moi le livre noir
allez je reviens ce sarkozy insiste et
essaye de récupérer un enfant à chaque
fois que l'occasion voir se présenter à
lui finalement et ça sera une espèce de
marchandage
et contre toute attente les enfants 8
sont remis finalement assez facilement
devra comprendre pourquoi parce que 21
petits-enfants qui crie qui pleure pour
certains copies ou le reste c'est
difficile à gérer
moins d'enfants il y aura dans la pièce
nuance portera donc dans un premier
temps le troc ça va être de le faire
c'est diminuer ce nombre d'otages et au
maximum qu'on
donc
tu amènes une caisse de pognon gamme de
bras gauche et amélie si le prix gauss
voilà c'est une mine standard
[Musique]
vas-y répondu c'est pasqua à l'eau sap
est très possible là c'est exact
rassurez vous votre femme va bien je
suis laurence dreyfus à l'eau non madame
souliers n'est pas là oui oui il va bien
non je peux pas trop parler là non je
viens standardiste
je pourrais peut-être en profiter pour
appeler ma fille est logée la moi
[Musique]
les enfants vont bien ils jouent
tranquillement ils sont sur la famille
opposé à la porte j'ai rencontré trois
fois
il était très calme tout ce qui est de
nature à inquiéter les parents ou delà
de la situation qui déjà en elle-même
est suffisamment inquiétante
c'est quelque chose que j'ai vite et je
fais en sorte de leur présenter une
image de stabilité lors donné confiance
et leur dire que la sphère est entre les
mains de professionnels c'est exquis
breaker et qu' on est là pour les aider
et non pas pour arriver à un drame
ils nous disent voilà ce qui va se
passer et ça se passe chaque fois on va
lui donner un poste de radio il ya un
enfant qui va sortir donc donc du coup
il nous toujours avant ils viennent nous
voir toutes les heures ils nous disent
voilà maintenant il va se passer ça
tu dois les négos pour une vidéo ça y
est c'est fini
[Musique]
c'est un moment de bonheur elle se sert
à moi très très très fortement et tout
de suite je demande qu'on prévienne
laurence mon épouse et mes béquilles
souri à la c ie magnifique ses grands
yeux bleus et au nez qui se demandent ce
qui se passe autour d'elle
pourquoi je l' enveloppe
dans
dans mon imperméable et pourquoi tout de
suite on s'engouffre dans un véhicule ça
va très vite les enfants arrive en
pleurant général parce qu'ils ont eu
peur d'eux ils ont peur d'eux des gens
du raid qui sont quand même très
impressionnant
tout d'un coup ils songent ils
traversent une cour en courant ils sont
jetés dans les bras de leurs parents
attention attend ce mal à les appeler un
médecin
il faut trouver un médecin volontaire
auprès du samu
une femme ce serait bien je lui propose
une de nos personnels médecin qui est
une femme et s'appelle evelyne lambert
je demande à ce qu elles viennent sur le
site malheureusement on ne peut pas
venir tout de suite sur le site et
katrien verheeke chic et médecins du
samu 92 se proposent spontanément de de
la remplacer
c'est le médecin du samu est ce qu elle
peut entrer tu veux rentrer vers 15h30
16h donc la prise d'otage date de 9
heures le matin
donc j'arrive à un moment où il ya des
petits gamins quatre ans qui sont pas
sortis du tout de cette classe depuis le
matin et qui sont cloîtrés dans un petit
espace
donc c'est descriptible comme souvent le
louma un grand garçon c'est bien peux
pas respirer ici il faudrait ouvrir une
fenêtre une minute non on est pas les
fenêtres le chercher des médicaments
le seul médicament si sa maman libérer
le ira beaucoup mieux je suis là vous
voyez
qu'est ce que vont apporter la moitié je
t'ouvre pouvoir partir
sacré là il est là vous inquiétez pas
vous pouvez le prendre aux élus ici la
regarde et je vais vous le donner comme
ça vous pourrez contrôler vous même
c'est un autre salle d'encadrer des
devises déjà 10 millions on m'attend
j'ai la maman qu'elle allait venu
chercher sa fille comment s'appelle la
vie alors je vous ai déjà donné un
enfant non je veux deux enfants contre
deux sacs
vous verrez bien ce cas dans les sacs
demande à l'institutrice de venir
vérifier
j'ai la maman qu'elle avoue voulait pas
lui laisser sa fille [__] je ne peux
pas laisser se faire martyriser cette
pauvre femme je lui ai promis si un
dixième de ce que je vous ai demandé la
wii vous m'avez demandé 100 millions
j'ai confiance en vous je vous laisse et
de sacs voulait compter jeu par une
demi-heure chercher des billets en plus
je pars un peu mieux avec la voiture et
personne
personne ne m'a jamais traité motor veut
pas traiter de menteur série ce qui me
fait plus de peine dans tout ça c'est
qu'un seul instant vous ayez pu croire
que je me moque êtes vous
[Musique]
le fait de demander une rançon aussi
importante
il s'inscrit automatiquement dans une
trajectoire des chèques et c'est ce qui
me fait dire et depuis depuis
pratiquement le début mai a fortiori
après coup qu'on est dans une chronique
d'un suicide annoncé
les parvis des halles aux toilettes non
ça va
pas de chance
le plan
il ya deux possibilités oui france
couloirs et les toilettes au fond ou
alors il ya cette pièce m'a qui sert de
salle de sport et on va le croire c'est
comment voit il y aura pas tout seul il
va y aller avec un gamin au maire de
lavabos du fond ils pissent dedans et
louis baillot le patron du raid tutrice
armement break au moins aller aux
toilettes
[Musique]
ne vous inquiétez pas
restez calme j'ai besoin de vous pouvez
nous montrer où sont les explosifs
après la porte et l'interrupteur qu'il
tient dans la main ils sont certainement
qu'il entend du bruit
il plonge sa main dans le sac la famille
il appuie sur quelque chose ou l'autre
main il a plusieurs interrupteur il les
bouges et la petite lampe rouge s'allume
carte savez sur sa poignée c'est bien
c'est pas c'est la puissance des
explosif où il a su après que si jamais
ça saute et non seulement les enfants
n'étaient plus là mais nous non plus
mais sur le coup on n'a pas conscience
on pense juste à ces enfants là en se
disant tout d'un coup on peut les voir
arriver à moitié brûlé et ça ça c'est
c'est horrible c'est effectivement le
samu qui me fait que prendre conscience
de ça
ira-t-il va pas rester très longtemps
elle sera remplacée capitaine evelyne
lambert et qui va jouer un rôle
prépondérant dans durant toute la sphère
qui a fait preuve d'un sang froid
extraordinaire
bonjour je m'appelle est vrai qu est-ce
qui est souffrant
7e
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas de fleur d'oranger qui
travaille au quai l'epitech tester mon
entrée dans votre carte
sa pop ou des médecins c'est dur aide
immédiate à l'eau la moitié
vous avez pu voir que la moitié gibert
et un enfant quand j'aurai tout un
ensemble
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent nous savions très peu de
choses mais tout à l'heure l'un de nos
reporters jean-pierre abou a été invité
à pénétrer à l'intérieur de l'école par
le preneur d'otage journaliste raconte
que des conneries pourrait dire que je
suis pas noir d'ébène prise d'otages
politiques
je suis pas d'action directe
c'est leur revendication c'est une
rançon 100 millions prend
si on verse pas la rançon si on essaie
d'intervenir
je suis prêt à tout faire sauter hbc
mois
tout à l'heure on a entendu charme lardy
qui le préfet des hauts-de-seine dire
que le dénouement était proche
est-ce qu'on a assisté à des éléments
qui peuvent faire penser à ce qu'il ya
de nouvelles en calories dans mes
enfants de nouvelles libérations déjà
d'en rire surtout après une journée
pareille qui luttent contre le sommeil à
s'allonger a pu se reposer d'accord je
suis fatigué pas vous allez on est allé
comme il ya tout allonge près du lit
avec le preneur d'otages pour qu'il
prenne enfin conscience de son geste et
qu'il relâche pour les enfants
je
[Musique]
e
on se promène dans la cour il fait il
fait doux et il fait nuit et on vois je
vois tous ces lits préparé avec des
couvertures de survie et tout ça et là
j'ai trouvé que c'était très très dur et
très violent donc je joue je suis rentré
j'ai et j'ai dit ça c'est très
désagréable
jamais vu autant d'argent de ma vie
combien je m'occupais des liasses de
sens
prenez une feuille la bombe à trier les
billets on fera plusieurs colonnes je
peux note au fur et à mesure si tu veux
j'ai bien combien
il ya des billets de 500 il ya des
billets de cent et les deux là aussi est
comptée à part ça c'est quoi ça c'était
d'être moi je me connais
bon
c'est moi qui vais compter
remettez tout dans le sac là
on met tout ça veut pas
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il ya ya combien dans ces sacs
monsieur je n'ai reçu de la banque à 25
millions avec les devises
j'ai encore deux sacs qu'ils sont là ya
25 millions là vous avez ma parole
d'honneur
il ya combien de dollars 570 lemarque
profond 85 alors il ya un million huit
cent quinze mille francs dans son sac
monsieur aumont il ya plus que ça
revient de sa part compter alors vous
savez qu'il ya aussi ces deux sacs là
elles vont rencontrer il ya dix ou vingt
fois moins que prévu
est-ce que vous avez aussi compter ses
deux sacs là non vous vous rendez compte
que vous m'avez demandé tout cet argent
à 3 heures de l'après midi que je me
suis débrouillé pour vous trouver tous
ses billets je vous ai demandé 100
millions de francs c'est ça que je vous
les donne monsieur moi j'en veux pas de
cet argent je veux pas le garder il est
pour vous un pour que vous puissiez
vivre avec ce pognon pourquoi est-ce
qu'on peut pas être horreur et tout ça
croyez qu'ils vont laisser heureux et
fier qui sont là-haut sur le toit on
touchera pas un seul de vos cheveux vous
me donnez les gamins vous ne risquez
rien rien vous aurez le pognon vous
aurez la voiture tout ce que vous voulez
simplement il faut pas me demander 100
millions parce que 100 millions même le
produit peut pas vous les trouvez dans
les passifs or elle vient également vous
avez raison ça prouve que vous êtes
quelqu'un de bien ça prouve que vous
aimez les enfants c'est ce que j'aurai
toujours dit plus vraiment
bon soyons clair pour les deux enfants
je veux c'est un papillon
on vous a dit à 50 millions en tout on
va l'écouter et vous donnera lé deuxième
en france il est bien ce qu en millions
donnez-moi le deuxième os x non je
téléphone au gouverneur de la banque de
france pour qu'ils rapportent lui-même
de l'argent je vais ouvrir la banque de
france il est en train de m'arnaquer là
j'en parle aux parents j'ai une mère de
famille qui attend dans le couloir juste
mon genre ou par leur rendez vous êtes
en train de tromper tout le monde mais
oui mais vous dire que je suis un [__]
vous dirai tout ce que vous voulez
d'accord moi je voulais ses deux sacs là
et je demande aux parents de vous
appeler pourrait leur dire tout ce que
vous pensez de moi de vous laisser
sortir la petite fille sacre opinion et
je vous donne la petite fille que si
vous faites je reprends mes sacs
pourquoi vous le prenez pour la raconter
mon dieu je veux pas encore quand vous
disais que je me moque de vous asseyez
vous écouter est-ce que j'ai vraiment la
tête de quelqu'un qui rigole non moi je
vois rigoler dans pas longtemps je sens
voilà je vais compter tout ça et je
reviens d'accord c'est nous qui allons
recompter d'accord mais vous me donnez
la petite non j'ai plus confiance
monsieur sarkozy attention hein
vous avez donné la mois non c'est fini
sentez vous plus relâchée d'enfants mais
dans le même temps nous nous avons
rassemblé les faux
le premier ministre a donné des
instructions au directeur de la banque
de france qui était pas très facile il
faut bien le reconnaître
d'ailleurs on ne parle pas que du halal
van van goolen entendre il a fallu que
le premier ministre nous nous mettions
en colère pour qu'ils comprennent ce
n'était pas une plaisanterie les et que
la vie des enfants arrêtés dangereux
c'est bientôt cet automne un petit
lézard se mit à pleurer
nous nous
pour beaucoup de problèmes madame et je
vois pas pourquoi tu à 22h 30 ans ou de
ma gueule j'espère que vous avez bien
compté je suis nul en calcul vous savez
quand ils vont installer l'interphone de
parents ou leurs annonces très con voir
de gros problèmes parce qu'une grande
différence entre ce que j'ai demandé ce
qu'on me donne je les verrai plus aucun
enfant tant que tout l'argent sera pas
apportée ici c'est la rançon et 100
millions qu'est ce que c'est que tu dois
classe la classe
j'avais demandé aux parents de faire
évacuer les gens qui sont au dessus je
personne a sans doute vu personne à côté
[Musique]
bonsoir ils ont trois ou quatre ans ils
sont 8 et à cette heure ci ils dorment
on imagine l'angoissé la torture qui
prouvent les parents depuis plus de
quatorze heures maintenant
alain chabot vous êtes sur place alors
où en est-on maintenant alors
effectivement christine un enfant a été
libérée tout à l'heure aux alentours de
23 heures il est donc sorti de cette
école maternelle du commandant charcot
et la soustraction nous donne en fait
cet enfant ou huit enfants donc toujours
entre les mains du preneur d'otages à
l'intérieur de cette salle de l'école
maternelle où il se trouve donc depuis
9h30 ce matin comme vous le disiez
christine laurence
les deux fois à côté de moi
[Musique]
comment pensez vous être terminée
je sais plus aucune chance je les flics
les tireurs d'élite de tête aux aguets
pour moi bat comme un chien mais non je
suis sans aucune envie de vous abattre
vous vous donnez l'argent que vous
réclamez ensuite vous allez partir
[Musique]
deux enveloppes à l'armoire
préparez une enveloppe pour chaque
enfant acteur dont dessus et vous
mettrez et 30 mille francs dans chaque
enveloppe ça quand ça sera fini par an
pour offrir de belles vacances et leurs
enfants comment vous pouvez proposer de
l'argent vous menacer leur vie de leur
enfant
penser qu'on peut oublier oubliez tout
ce que vous faites tous les sachets de
temps n'arrive bien sûr tout s'achète
pas question que je vais accepter
l'argent de la rançon
parler comme ça maintenant mais grâce à
moi vous allez devenir une vedette
d'aller faire la une des journaux faudra
tout savoir sur vous vous habitez avec
louis iv où il vient prendre trente
mille francs
votre mari au nez
vous
[Musique]
mais là on attendre
voila je viens de la banque de france
geraghty c'est tout ce que je pouvais
ratisser sac mignon opus verra ça demain
vous vous rendez compte qu'il est une
heure du matin que j'ai tenu ma promesse
maintenant il faut me donner la petite
laura j'ai promis à sa mère de la durée
mais alors est en train de dormir avec
sur le dos je vous en supplie de donner
là moi j'ai tout fait un jeu peut rien
faire de plus moi j'ai besoin de laura
pour être crédible vis-à-vis des parents
si je ne suis pas crédible vis-à-vis des
parents je peux plus rien contrôler pour
l'évacuation
qu'est-ce que vous avez une tournure
après l'évacuation jeu fourni le camion
va pas le camion et l'espace je fournis
la route saint phalle je fournis tout ce
que vous voulez madame passez moi
l'enfant s'il vous plaît
on
la machette
quand j'ai publié mon avis il reprend la
petite là je sais pas moi je croyais que
vous étiez d'accord alors je dois vous
demanderez c'est bien des enfants qui
sortent ici
vous avez promis payer
[Musique]
six familles ont passé six ans
ce n'est prêt à vous viendrez d'êtres
vivants résolu
comme d'hab nous revenons sur cette
prise d'otage de neuilly d'abord
stéphane soumier au terme d'une nuit
d'attentes d'une nuit d'angoissé devant
la maternelle
conny la nuit d'un contraste le calme
des enfants dans leur salle de classe au
rez de chaussée les efforts d'une
institutrice pour les faire jouer
[Musique]
organiser une réunion de tous les
parents de renty la liberté tous les
visiteurs un des enfants bien sûr je ne
trouve jamais repartir je vous garantis
le monde et que les enfants soient
endormis
vous imaginez le choc pour les parents
oui je suis pas nos enfants
les flics qui font exprès de mentir
inquiéter le bar on pourra me battre
[Musique]
donner aux parents
elles avaient pour instruction de la
part d' achever de remettre un certain
nombre de documents de ce type pour les
parents
quand elle arrive dans la salle le
gymnase je commence à sortir la liasse
et à donner les documents par an donc là
tout de suite je m'empare des documents
et
et je suis franchement je me souviens
pas comment je dois le poisson dans
l'ensemble les parents sont calmes parce
que on nous transmet une information qui
dès qu'il n'est pas totale je ne serai
pas pris vivant méfiez-vous de la police
la sauvegarde de vos enfants dépend de
ma sécurité fait pression pour que
toutes mes exigences aboutisse et je
n'échangerais aucune parole
on nous donne à papier comme ça ou bien
fourni les parents m in a more vu cette
situation dure que les enfants seront
traumatisés vraiment d'accord avec vous
je comprends pas votre argent
on a mis des voitures à votre
disposition je pense pas mourir [__]
ah bon je crois sincèrement que vous
êtes quelqu'un de bien vous trompez
comment vous des mômes vous avez
toujours pensé jusqu'ici pense aussi à
la mienne encore vous vous avez pensé à
tous vous avez votre plan pour vous
évader
nous on a été pris par surprise on a le
temps pour ça rien dire camille a rendu
son ghetto voilà
tous cherchent autant mais bon on va
appeler quelqu'un et qu'il va faire
chauffer
[Musique]
neymar de prise d'otages j'en ai marre
de vos caprices de vos humeurs
vous avez pensé aux parents à la douleur
que vous leur faites en durée c'est
ignoble
j'en peux plus moi je vais revoir ma
fille je vais vous le fatiguer je vous
préviens si vous n'arrêtez pas
maintenant c'est moi qui devais partir
et je reviens d'un pas arrêter ces
conversations
tant pis pour vous demander si vous
partez je sais que vous reviendrez
[Musique]
c'est pas le fait qu'ils soient tous
seuls avec les enfants qui peut nous
inquiéter
ce qui va nous inquiéter c'est qu'il va
dire est ce que l'on va entendre
maintenant vous allez c'est moi qui vais
vous gardez au nez assis sur le banc je
sais pas samedi à damas montrent comment
tu t'appelles toi toi je dit camila et
toi comment tu t'appelles ça se traite
pourquoi c'est un secret parce que
pourquoi pas ici ils s'arrêtent les
bandits ne sont pas gentils ils prennent
l'argent ça je vais pas le prévenu à
pékin pour nous délivrer d'un seul coup
nous entendons décrit alors les crises
et au secours au secours et
de l'autre côté on se dit ça y est il
est en train de nous en nous on tueur a
été tout on a failli entrer dans les
lieux mais
on n'est pas rentré parce que parce que
l'un des gamins et puis tous les autres
se sont mis à rire mais là on allait
rentrer donc le groupe dassault
d'urgence son but c'était justement
d'empêcher que d'autres enfants soient
éliminés et sauver ce que ce que l'on
pouvait sauver
[Musique]
allez jouer je demandais une réunion
avec tous les parents on n'entend plus
personne n'entre ni sarkozy ni évident
ni vous c'est agréable terminé c'est
terminé foot est la porte
je reste là
[Musique]
en mai la banque sortait est fermé
à
fois tiré la langue c'est pas beau
lauras je rends pas laurence moi tu le
dos rond d'écran je m'appelle je vais te
dire lequel le bandit dit oui je suis un
bandit c'est pas beau le banc dire je
suis méchant
ce n'est pas méchant
[Musique]
je me promets de relativiser pas mal de
choses qu'on peut dire de homps nerfs
pour des choses qui sont idiotes un
enfant qu'à trois ans et demi et
finalement c'est pas grave on vit dans
on vit en faisant des montagnes de
choses qui sont qui sont idiotes et
qu'en fait on ferait mieux de de
profiter de tout ce qui est bien et de
part et d'autre part voilà ce s'énerver
pour des idiots
[Musique]
ad
or et des châteaux a déjà tant je vais
te sauter
[Musique]
arrêté le château ne répondent plus au
téléphone jeudi tout et chacun non c'est
bolliger sur méchant je veux vous voir
je sais qu'on veut me tuer il ya déjà
cotée qui sabre et des pieds dessus et
ville du mans et les policiers avaient
vraiment besoin c'est moi qui demande le
procureur de la république de reprendre
le fil des négociations
je pense qu'effectivement hb sur
insensible au fait que le procureur de
la république se déplace en personne
pour discuter avec lui
le chef du raid est très mécontent des
instructions du ministre d'intérieur
ils le manifestent par des gestes très
clair car il estime vraisemblable longue
c'est une erreur et je ne peux pas le
lui reprocher parce que effectivement il
me connaît pas et il ne sait pas du tout
comment je vais réagir après
[Musique]
en judo
on voit rien vous voyez il n'y a rien du
tout je suis le procureur de la
république
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que
vous craignez
qu'on vous fasse un mauvais coup si
c'est ça moi j'ai comme obligation
d'assurer votre protection et je m'y
engage
si nous sortons ensemble moi je vous
protège
en combien de temps le temps qu'il faut
on monte ensemble en voiture et on part
je suis votre garantie je fais mettre la
voiture devant la porte et on part
combien de kilomètres ça je ne peux pas
le dire comment ça se passera quand je
vous relâcherait pardon je peux vous
gardé des bilans non vous n'allez pas me
prendre comme otages il n'en est pas
question
je lui ai dit je me rendrai pas vivant
[Musique]
marine ya ici
écoutez on ne peut pas avoir un
comportement comme ça avec les enfants
et vouloir leur mort c'est pas possible
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
officiel avec les enfants je m'en
occuper est-ce que vous accepteriez que
le médecin reviennent non il a refusé
tout ce que j'ai des bons des
appartements n'ont pas besoin d'une
phase dure les flics arrêtent à dire aux
parents que je suis dangereux
vous aurez tendance à une caméra il veut
une caméra pour montrer aux parents que
telle ne maltraite pas les enfants donc
on aura cette caméra à l'intérieur que
nous donnera quand même une ambiance
plus quelques micro qu'on aura placé
donc on aura à la fois l'oreille à la
fois les yeux les yeux un peu moins bons
pleurait quand
[Musique]
ouais la dynamique la bamba auprès de la
porte
[Musique]
on fait pas la caméra sont rois
pierre lyon-caen discute avec hp et hb
lui dit que il est prêt à se défaire de
ses explosifs mais à condition d'avoir
une arme et puis on entend lui répond
que non il n'en est pas question
pia lyon caen revient et là je dis à pia
long quand nous les gens du raid nous
savons nous comporter en présence de
quelqu'un qui porte une arme pas en
présence de quelqu'un qui détient que de
l'explosif mais en présence de quelqu'un
qui a une arme nous savons nous
comporter donc vous pouvez vous pouvez y
aller
il me semble bizarre je vous fais une
proposition tout à fait officielle vous
reprenez vos bâtons de dynamite vous les
mettez dans votre sac ou désactiver les
explosifs
vous remettez le sac à un policier qui
vous donne le revolver avec le chargeur
je vous arrête je pas resté dix minutes
avec seulement envers l'état pour me
défendre
si vous avez un otage auquel vous mettez
sur la tempe un revolver vous ne pensez
pas qu'on va prendre un risque
quelconque véritable mais d'aucune
utilité
j'ai travaillé je n'aurai pas le temps
de m'en servir face et aux gens du redda
il ya interdiction de sortir avec les
explosifs et alarmes qu'on vous donne ne
peut pas aller plus loin
je lance un ultimatum comme vous voulez
mais on ne cédera pas
[Musique]
la deuxième nuit commence on est fatigué
on n'a pas du tout dormi la nuit d'avant
donc on a installé dans l'impression que
ça peut durer longtemps
je ne sait plus à quelle heure mais
relativement tard le soir
michel de marie vient nous voir nous dit
là on arrête tout il se passe plus rien
il faut que tout le monde dorme ou voit
demain matin
le tilloy marina d'un moment tu te vois
dedans
barrière je ne vois pas ma main quand tu
la vois pas mais elle te vois puis
bonjour jours
réméré peut pas ne répond pas parce que
ça marche dans un sens comme dans
l'autre
l'important c'est qu'elle voit qu'en
pleine forme
[Musique]
je vais vous aider à cocher les filles
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé 100 millions
non parce que j'ai une chance sur cent
millions d'en sortir
[Musique]
une solution aux jets par les enfants
une seule s'est voulu tout faire sauter
je me fasse sauter
est ce que vous croyez que c'est
vraiment indispensable ce que vous êtes
prêts à prendre votre part de
responsabilité
oui bien sûr
si vous êtes en mesure de trouver un
médicament qui m'aident à en finir je
suis d'accord je suis médecin
ce n'est pas mon rôle
[Musique]
en fin de soirée le médecin capitaine
des pompiers me dis que l'autre je
constate que l'odeur de cette pièce est
pestilentielle et qu'elle ne ne conçoit
pas de n'imagine pas de passer la nuit
dans cette odeur et sans pour la santé
même des enfants il est nécessaire
d'aérer cette pièce non c'est un conte
cacher derrière
je reste là pendant ces quelques minutes
ensuite on fermera ça suffit vous pouvez
peut-être accepter qu on la laisse
entrouverte comme sa voix sera pas toute
la nuit
hassan ont fermé le rideau pardon ça
vous commandez j'accepte de vous obéir
mais uniquement sur ce point
prévenir en cas d'intervention bien sûr
ça fait déjà presque 40 heures qu'on est
en place tout le monde est fatigué mais
bon nous c'est rien mais les enfants ont
maintenant longtemps et celui qui
m'inquiète
et c'est le preneur d'otages parce que
je vois qu'il est arrivé à un point de
rupture
alors
est-ce qu'il va tenir le coup est ce
qu'il va commettre une maladresse est ce
que c est ce que ça là il faut il faut
faire quelque chose qu'il faut agir
[Musique]
prisonnier de mes rêves les plus fous je
suis mal assis sur une petite chaise
d'enfant
il est 4 heures dans la pénombre de
cette classe en rideau ou auchan le
jardin rempli d'hommes noirs et aux
fenêtres masquée par les dix-sept sa
bombe a donc quelques heures pour moi
tout sera fini je ne sais pas encore si
ce sera la balle d'un sniper du raid
on maîtrise qui voleront dans un grand
moment rien trouvé une boîte en métal
pour quoi faire
je suis obligé de canche exclusion jeu
qu'on retrouve les écrits sera ma vote
nord
[Musique]
je vais sauter avec brio là où d'autres
auraient vécu et une minuterie t
[Musique]
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord pour
l'endormir c'est à dire que on va faire
la demande aux médecins qui sont
présents de nous aider à trouver un
produit suffisamment insipide pour qu'on
puisse le mélanger à du café mon opinion
personnelle immédiate est que ce sera
nous mais je ne peux pas prendre cette
décision tout seul faut qu'on en discute
il ya plein de questionnements
déontologie qui a compris et titre qui
se pose avec cette question on a sept ce
rôle de prestations décalées on est là
pour ça si on mélange ça avec un autre
rôle qui serait un rôle d'intervenant
prestataires de la police on perd toute
la crédibilité du rôle de cette
structure qu'elle s'amuse à dire que
plus jamais on ne peut intervenir en
disant nous on est là comme médecin
notre bourse est médecin
est-ce que je suis d'accord pour que on
l'endort bien entendu je suis d'accord à
condition que ça n'ait pas de
conséquences vitales sur l'intéressé
dd
[Musique]
au monde et que ce café
tu crever
c'est vrai si on avait mis des
somnifères d'enquêté
[Musique]
vers 10h par là se méfier t'inquiète à
la nuit va attendre de se relâcher
[Musique]
en tout
alors
réveillez vous
aviez-vous
[Musique]
moi je part de l'hypothèse que le
produit n'a pas fait des faits et que
il dort son sommeil peut être léger et
je donne des instructions aux gens qui
vont intervenir
je leur dis de ne pas hésiter à tirer
s'il bouge ne serait-ce qu'un oeil
[Musique]
on savait
vous savez ce qu'on va faire non on doit
jouer les tortues qui veut jouer tout le
monde caché sous les matières attention
joie des têtes
sarah
[Musique]
peu ont volontairement voir
involontairement faire déclenché son
dispositif et moi je suis très sceptique
quant à l'issue favorable de l'opération
je suis persuadé que qui l'a piégé c'est
son sac que ça va sauter mais bon il
faut y aller faut y aller
[Musique]
fin du cauchemar pour les six enfants et
leur maîtresse retenu en otage pendant
46 heures à neuilly sur seine
libéré à 7h25 ce matin par les policiers
du raid
quand tu es le preneur d'otages je crois
qu'on va essayer de se couper de tout ça
et de
et de reprendre une vie normale et et
retrouver notre spontanéité je récupère
ma fille est la première chose qu'elle
me dis pourquoi t'es pas venu me
chercher dans la classe et je lui dis
parce qu'il y avait un méchant monsieur
dans ta classe
elle me dit non maman il est pas méchant
je veux pas penser à ce moment à ce
monstre c'est une délivrance pour tous
ceux qui ont été victimes
ça n'est pas un chantage étaient prêts à
se faire sauter à faire sauter toute
l'école et tout ce qu'ils étaient je
suis soulagée que ce soit terminé
peu importe de quelle manière en tout
cas que ce soit bien terminé pour les
enfants qui étaient restés
le cauchemar est terminé il était très
important que les enfants soient
libérées en bonne santé
c'était notre objectif essentiel le shbo
le second qui n'est pas négligeable
c'était que force reste à la loi
nouvelle que forcené est mort d'abord
content d'avoir sauvé les sites it fille
quand même l'objectif de l'opération
mais malheureusement il a fallu pour
pour cela tuer quelqu'un et il n'y a pas
de véritablement de titres de gloire en
retirer quand le preneur d'otages était
porteur de documents d'identité au nom
d'eric schmidt
cette identité est actuellement
vérifiées eric schmidt se faisait
appeler achevé comme human bomb
il avait sur lui 24 bâtons de dynamite
divorcé sans enfant sa dernière activité
professionnelle connue et l informatique
ils se trouvaient au chômage depuis le
printemps 92 après avoir été licencié
dans la banlieue parisienne
selon l'un de ses amis il serait ensuite
parti sans pouvoir honorer ses dettes et
sans laisser d'adressé
j'ai ressenti si cette personnalité
comme ayant à un égo très fort en fait
c'était quelqu'un qui avait probablement
une idée de lui-même qui était
très très hot très ambitieuse sa vie
professionnelle avec un échec
il a sans doute très très mal supporté
dans la mesure où il avait tout investi
et moi je ne sais pas pourquoi il a été
tué je ne sais pas pourquoi je ne
comprends pas pourquoi
comment peut-il avoir un geste menaçant
dans la mesure où il dort si réellement
les intéressés a été abattu alors qu'il
dormait c'est un assassinat
rien moins si en revanche il a été
abattu alors qu'il se réveillait et donc
il retrouvait toute sa dangerosité
alors cela les conditions légitime
défense aurait il est couché
latéralement et tout à coup il ouvre un
oeil et à ce moment il fait un mouvement
de relèvement
il va en direction du sac dans lequel il
a la main donc là je tire trois fois le
fait qu'il ait pu bouger résulte de la
seule déclaration de ceux qui l'ont mis
en joue la position dans laquelle ils
étaient ne le rendait pas dangereux
c'est très désagréable se trouvait dans
une position de suspect alors que
quelques heures ou jours avant on était
considérés comme des héros effectivement
très désagréable c'est vrai que ça fait
très mal au coeur mais bon faut dire
aussi que c'est ça qui est un peu le
garant aussi de d'une certaine
déontologie
bon parfois accepter de se faire
critiquer qu'on puisse remettre en cause
éventuellement nos méthodes
ça permettait d'avoir une police plus
sereine et plus république s'est passé
peut-être pas plus mal
[Musique]
on